3 de mont-saint-martin deux guerriers
naguère se faisait la guerre je tuerai
pour un maquis temps piment alors qu'il
est con toi petit quelque chose
les frères grandir séparément jusqu'à
atteindre un nas critique la quarantaine
papa s complétait bien bon noël cette
année mon lapin parfois les gens se
perdent de vue
ok on peut pas tout arrangé avec du fric
bien sûr que c'est m t'as pas changé du
tout est toujours un gros bébé c'est ça
des droits tout cela déclenche avec cet
été excusez moi ça m'ennuie
d'interrompre une conversation si
captivante mais pourquoi qui n'en
suscite pas une chacun
[Musique]
elle sait parler et beaucoup j'ai
reprend l affaire de famille et
maintenant vous bossez pour moi les
boumeurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baby corp a conçu un nouveau l'équipe
transformer un adulte un bébé pendant 48
heures tu veux que je redevienne un bébé
[Musique]
ça c'est l'âge ingrat baby corp assure à
l'effacement total de la mémoire après
cette expérience
alors quel est le problème un génie du
mal on apprend aux enfants à être de
très près il un bébé bienvenue à la
révolution des bébés il va nous falloir
un déguisement pour nous un fil très
sérieux on va faire quoi de la voile aux
nounous
merci d'être toujours là pour me couvrir
tu es mon frère on reste toujours
ensemble c'est comme ça dans une famille
qu'on se dépêche avant que les perdre
son pouvoir
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce
vous êtes trop mimi dans vos petites
tenues de ninja
[Musique]
je suis sûr que ça peut s'arranger avec
du fric c'est quoi ce binz